une idée de sortie à présent pour ce
week-end dans les Yvelines si vous êtes
amateur de rock ou non la seconde
édition du ouest musique festival et de
retour à molette c'est ce dimanche de
11h à 21h pour en parler avec nous
Stéphane gornes le maire de la commune
alors pour le West Music Festival
l'ambiance américaine et complètement au
rendez-vous exactement il ne reste plus
qu'à chausser les centièmes et mettre
son chapeau de cow-boy et puis venir
passer un après-midi enfin toute une
journée d'ailleurs ça démarre à 11h ça
finit à 21h30
il y aura cinq concerts qui vont se
dérouler s'enchaîner toute la journée
avec des animations également
de la restauration qui est prévue sur
place
des expositions de voitures alors et de
moto alors orienté Harley Davidson pour
les motos orienté voiture américaine
côté voiture
pourquoi ce thème pourquoi être parti
sur sur l'Amérique et tout ce côté là
américain pour pour ce festival à
molette
c'était une histoire de rencontre j'ai
rencontré alors ça part un peu loin mais
vous allez voir un peu le rapport après
j'ai rencontré en fait Brigitte et
Pierre qui sont tous les deux
enfin président et vice-présidente de
l'association
d'éducation canine de molette et le jour
où je les reçois ils avaient tous les
deux un t-shirt Harley Davidson et
j'avais dans l'idée de créer un festival
en fait à molette et je voulais pas
faire un festival autour enfin un peu
classique j'allais dire comme justement
la fête de la musique je voulais faire
quelque chose d'un petit peu particulier
et puis on en discutant avec eux ils
nous ont ils me disent bah écoute nous
on peut organiser une rencontre avec
justement un regroupement d'Harley
Davidson
et puis de fil en aiguille on s'est dit
bah tiens Harley Davidson l'Ouest
américain et bah ce serait peut-être
l'occasion effectivement de faire un
festival autour de du rock et des
États-Unis voilà vous l'avez dit à
l'instant tout au long de la journée il
va y avoir cinq groupes de musique qui
vont se succéder je vous propose
d'écouter un extrait on en parle juste
après
[Musique]
alors c'est une très grosse
programmation rock Stéphane Bernay
donc s'enchaîner sur sur toute la
journée les fuzzles en fait c'est le
premier groupe à 11h alors c'est vrai
que un début de festival c'est toujours
un peu compliqué parce que il y a pas
beaucoup de monde en fait au départ donc
j'espère que ce groupe va attirer du
monde justement il passe quand même
souvent sur sur les scènes aussi bien de
de
des Yvelines que d'Île-de-France ou même
ailleurs donc c'est plutôt du blues rock
pour pour ce groupe ensuite on a vu les
Red cabège les Red cabège c'est plutôt
de la country et en fait pendant cette
leur présentation enfin leur
représentation il va y avoir aussi des
cours de danse exactement de country
ensuite les harvest Blues Band étaient
déjà là l'an dernier ils ont mis le feu
au festival et donc on espère que ça va
être le cas encore cette année donc
c'est plutôt de la et du blues ensuite
les Dream On donc c'est du rock et du
blues aussi et on termine avec les
freaky Billy qui est du rock des années
50 donc avec des reprises comme Little
Richard ou Elvis alors autre dimension
de ce festival les motos et les
véhicules un peu de collection
c'est pourquoi c'est c'était important
de faire un regroupement de véhicules de
collection et bon on a voulu oui ça
attire effectivement et puis on a voulu
vraiment essayer de reproduire un petit
peu ce qu'on peut retrouver aux
États-Unis quand il y a des festivals
donc exposition de moto les groupes
viennent alors finalement j'ai une moto
je peux venir il y a pas de problème je
veux dire c'est pas sûr réservation il a
pas fallu appeler la mairie pour pouvoir
venir exposer sa moto ce sont souvent
des collectionneurs ce sont souvent des
gens qui font partie de de d'association
de de
de de passionnés de moto ou de voitures
et qui vont venir donc exposer leur
véhicule toute la journée
de Chevreuse et tout ça ils sont ils
sont ils sont énormément et il y a
beaucoup de plus en plus même à Paris
une grande une grande manifestation sur
les voitures les anciennes voitures et
tout ça c'est vrai que c'est je trouve
que ça ça revient et même au niveau
national et tout ça revient ça revient à
la mode et il y en a qui qui c'est des
vrais collectionneurs et ils
chouchoutent leurs
bécane et leur voiture mais c'est tout
un et ça revient je trouve que c'est
c'est top je veux dire il associe je
trouve avec
l'associe avec un festival ah ouais top
bravo
exactement donc vraiment on a envie
d'être dans l'ambiance américaine encore
une fois donc effectivement du rodéo
alors pas sur un taureau pas sur un vrai
taureau ça sera interro mécanique
mécanique
mais bon c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal
il faut réussir à tenir je crois que le
record c'est quel c'est même pas 10
secondes je crois
et puis après des activités aussi pour
les enfants donc des jeux gonflables un
manège qui va tourner enfin voilà donc
l'idée c'est vraiment vous arrivez à 11h
vous pouvez manger sur place vous passez
la journée vous vous amusez avec les
enfants il y a des food truck également
qui sont prévus avec différentes
spécialités et puis des spécialités
aussi de sucreries pour l'après-midi un
stand de bonbons qui fait je crois plus
de 20 mètres de long enfin voilà c'est
il y a vraiment de quoi faire merci
beaucoup Stéphane vernest d'avoir
accepté notre invitation en plateau pour
parler du ouest musique festival pour
rappel ce sera ce dimanche donc 25 juin
de 11h à 21h dans la commune de Maulette